on n'existait pas il fallait l'inventer
c'est chose faite il s'agit bien sûr de
la route des vins du jura elle s'ajoute
depuis ce week-end donc à la route du
comté à celle des microtechniques dont
en profite pour fêter la fleur dans la
vigne les témoins de cette naissance au
claudine longhi et michel serrault
il a du bouquet une belle robe sac ou
l'aurait assassiné sont des envieux mais
qui est ce le voc mesdames messieurs ce
doux et subtile breuvage qu'il faut
savoir apprécier fait aussi partie des
atouts du jura il manquait un circuit
touristique à la région il est enfin né
ce week-end en avant première quelques
privilégiés ont pu à bord de voitures
anciennes
noblesse oblige ouvrir officiellement la
route des vins du jura sur près de 80
kilomètres de salins les bains à
saint-amour bourgs et villages
s'égrènent au pied des coteaux
ensoleillés et couverts de vignes arrêt
dégustation et groupes folkloriques
étaient au programme est à bourg mans
mais aussi touristique dans les belles
pierres des domaines de renom un
agréable mariage voulu les pères de la
route des vins sont satisfaits au lard
ou du vin c'est une façon agréable
d'abord de faire de la promotion d'abord
oui mais c'est aussi pour occuper nos
gens les gens qui séjournent dans la
région ou dans le jura trouveront un
thème ou une pour occuper une journée ou
deux journées c'est également une façon
de faire découvrir agents pour
simplement les gens qui la traversent
les gens qui passent sur les nationales
à travers le fléchage qu'on a mis en
place on leur dit écoutez passé dans le
pays ne restez pas sur la nationale
découvre étaient ceux de nouveau on
espère une meilleure diffusion de nos
produits qui manquent déjà jusqu'à
maintenant seulement de contre mal enfin
avec une amplification de la bd
dans leur domaine des vins dure en
général à vous maintenant d'honorer
comme il se doit et d' apprécier sans
modération ce nouveau circuit
le rendez-vous 91 est déjà pris la fête
de la fleur de vigne entre dans la
tradition